Thank You Adam Evan chat let's get an F
in chat going but we didn't actually
start at the same doesn't matter there
are the apps the apps are now like this
starting pistol shot like everyone's
like yeah start your engines so we all
we everybody's been saying World War
three every single time something
happens I remember a few years ago it
was what was it called Israel did one of
their they call it mowing the lawn when
Israel fires a bunch of missiles and
blows a bunch of missile sites in Gaza
mowing the lawn they called mowing the
lawn yeah Wow it happens like every two
years I remember that happening in like
2014 or something and people are like oh
man World War three because Iran is
gonna retaliate and nothing happens and
then you know then you have this recent
thing where you know Iraq and sulemani
and everyone's like all World War three
and then nothing happens you know but
only a couple months later like not even
we have this global pandemic and while
everyone's paying attention to
themselves a bunch of things have
started happening around the world so
we've got some crazy conspiracies for
you today yeah it's gonna be a whole lot
of fun it's pretty intense the stuff
though I mean they're it's not some of
its not conspiracy it's like this
stuff's actually happening y'all almost
got it that's what is crazy to me some
of the stuff that's actually happened
and so we've we've got a bunch of
stories when you zoom out of the you
know the smaller picture and you look at
the whole world it does kind of look
like World War 3 is coming it really
does because there's like stuff
happening in China there's stuff
happening in Iran there's stuff
happening in Venezuela that's the lead
story right Venezuela rammed a cruise
ship opened fire sank Trump's deploying
the Navy that's crazy
yeah but we but we also beyond that
we've got stories about 5g someone
apparently torched a 5g tower and then
we turns out there's a a woke movie
called Chuck that got zero dollars at
the box office
nothing they nobody want to see it I
wouldn't have seen it I wouldn't want it
you didn't see it it's true so before we
get started make sure you join the super
chat by giving a super chat we will do
our best to read as many comments as we
can but admittedly lots of people
already you know putting in this sending
us super chat so I'll read what we can
hit the subscribe button hit that like
button it really does how
the show and we're gonna you know what
else we'll follow us we got our names up
above and yeah subscribe to education
below this story is insane and man yeah
I didn't believe it I swear I swear I
didn't believe it let me read that line
Venezuelan Navy vessel sinks after
opening fire on a cruise ship Trump
recently announced that he was they were
like yesterday they announced Trump was
deploying anti drug naval vessels to
Venezuelan waters or not to there was
but near there yeah that story came out
before this story this story's coming
out now but this incident happened on
March 30th so you know Trump knew that
Venezuela attacked a cruise ship okay so
this didn't happen like yesterday no
this happened on the Florida four days
ago yep yesterday us to deploy anti drug
Navy ships near Venezuela war it's not
just that man yeah this is the move of
war you want to see the scariest thing
yeah this freaked me out when you showed
me check this out
see all these alerts this is for the
most part the State Department issuing
travel alerts for evacuations from
countries all over the world now of
course this could just be you know kovat
related for sure I want to make sure
it's very clear as we move through all
of these crazy stories and the crazy
stuff I show you I'm not here to draw
any conclusions it's really easy to pull
up 50 stories and then be like it all
goes together that's the problem with
conspiracy theories yeah but what I want
to do is stop focusing on one thing
there I know a lot of people they're
journalists for say the the Southeast
Asia region okay and they're like oh man
all the stuffs happening and you ask
them about Central America and uncle I
don't know okay well what about Iran oh
I don't know there's people who cover
Mena the Middle East and North Africa
they don't know anything about what's
going on China a little bit okay when
you step back and look at all these
things you start you start to see well
the world is in conflict for sure yeah
does it really mean World War three I
don't know but I will I will like to
entertain some of the conspiracy
theories that have been popping up as of
late so as you know what was it like
January we went after sulla meny in Iran
oh it's January yep feels like forever
yeah maybe I don't even I don't remember
six and a half years ago
was it before January no it was it was
early January and I remember it was
January but then Iran you know a
civilian plane got blown up all those
crazy stuffs happening and people were
like World War 3 now we have this I'm
gonna walk through a bunch of stuff we
got South China Sea we got travel
advisories we've got Iran we got
Venezuela check out this story from the
Washington free beacon a Venezuelan Navy
vessel opened fire on a German cruise
ship but sank after it sustained severe
damages while ramming the luxury liner
on Monday morning the our CGS resolute a
123 metre long cruise ship equipped with
pole for polar expeditions was
performing routine maintenance in
international waters up the coast of
Venezuela on Monday according to a
statement by Columbia cruise services
which manages the ship soon a Venezuelan
patrol boat approached demanded the ship
divert its course to a Venezuelan port
the patrol boat then opened fire on the
resolute and repeatedly rammed it the
resolute has a reinforced hull built to
survive in arctic conditions and
sustained only minor damages in the
encounter the same could not be sent
said for its aggressor that's very sad
Venezuela try but giggle it's funny you
get like your RAM in a boat they're just
a cruise ship like it's long races that
a cruise ship is better armored than the
Venezuelan Navy yes you gotta understand
it's funny right
it's actually scary you know I know I
agree it is no no you know it's scared
that it's sank in their army is weak
Venezuela is desperate right now you've
got you know apparently Trump contacted
Saudi Arabia and Russia and said you
know shut down all oil production
because the oil prices are getting too
low something I could be wrong
fact-checking on that one but I can't
tell you there's an oil price war
happening and the prices are dropping
dramatically like we just saw gas the
other day for like a buck ninety three
remember that but isn't there isn't
there like a the demand is gone like
right great so yeah I guess I mean
wouldn't that make sense that is
dropping because they're just trying to
sell it and so Venezuela's principle
production is oil and they struggle so
now they got nothing
their money is worthless and the only
thing they really have nobody wants yeah
so what do they do
piracy go row were they going to get
from for their country from the cruise
a couple months worth of food for the
administration for Maduro for higher-ups
maybe the fastest if it's that yeah man
yeah dude it's been getting bad yeah and
remember what I said we were talking
about this like a couple weeks ago
all it takes is for one of these
countries to start getting desperate as
resources start drying up and then
they're gonna say it's me or them I
choose me now what I said before is like
I don't know where it would start maybe
maybe Vietnam right maybe maybe you know
South China Sea China will be like our
economy's taking a hit maybe it'll be a
Vietnam well I don't know it's a oh what
is this does a vagina ship hits and
sinks Vietnamese fishing boat in South
China Sea entertains the crew man that's
crazy now here's the thing this thing
here's the thing this happening does
this happen often it happens it does
China China's been trying to seize the
South China Sea for a while yeah right
but this is April 3rd you know we talked
about them lazing a flight right yeah
like two months ago and we were kind of
like yeah it's crazy it probably wasn't
anything now we've got this whole new
these new glasses that were wearing it's
like they take a look this I don't think
it was just uh them testing something I
feel like they were threatening it's
crazy was this Marines Marines will help
make it clear that China can't expel
America from the South China Sea oh I
know some Marines my brother's one of
them and they're serious man yep
those guy wouldn't mess with the Marines
you know China lazed a us like
surveillance plane of some sort they
just sank a Vietnamese fishing boat this
conflicts been going on for a while you
add all this stuff together
Venezuela might be the spark and the
powder keg who do they have any allies
who's Venezuela's allies I don't know do
they even have any but robably gonna be
Iran and Russia yeah well Russia just
sent us stuff do you think they
booby-trapped it all maybe Trump has
been trying to repair relations with
Russia for you though yeah he has and
now they've sent us a bunch of medical
t's yeah like people were trying to
twist it in some way but it's like how
they gave us help well thank you like
can you say that it's like that
attitude that we that those people have
what do you think Russia when they see
that what do you think they think you
know they're like oh wow
they're they're knocking Trump who said
it's a good thing we're we were trying
to help and they're like they're making
fun of oh they're making fun of us like
and they're saying that we're against
them it's kind of like I mean I'm I
don't know any Russians I don't know
what the the atmosphere is between us
right now but it's like all I know is
that they're sending us help and yes
that's nice
see it's important context because I'm
not trying to sit here and legitimately
say we can confirm something like World
War three or an international conflict
I'm just saying like I said it's easy to
pull up these stories and you've if you
forget to mention Russia sending us aid
right if you forgot to mention that
Trump has recently said you know we're
gonna do work at work with China to some
certain degree then you know it sounds
like things are getting worse but I
still think it's important to highlight
stuff like this if Venezuela so
apparently they were trying to ram this
cruise ship to force it into Venezuelan
waters now Venezuela is claiming that
the ship had mercenaries on it how do we
know that they're not they're making it
up they're nice these are these are
crazy people oil is worthless there
they've resorted to piracy and so they
saw a cruise ship hey man a cruise ship
is like a floating town that's true you
know yeah you're voting hotel tons of
oil tons of resources worth a lot of
money what do they get from it I don't
know what's a cruise ship costs hundreds
of millions of dollars to build yeah and
they can hold it hostage seize it and
then demand a ransom or something yeah
they're getting desperate it seems like
you know check this out this is
presumably unrelated us to deploy
anti-drug Navy ships near Venezuela The
Associated Press reports Donald Trump
announced Wednesday that Navy ships are
being moves toward Venezuela as his
administration beefs up counter
narcotics operations in the Caribbean
following u.s. drug indictments against
Nicolas Maduro the announcement came at
the start of the daily White House press
briefing to discuss the corona virus
pandemic which has left much of the
country in lockdown and we get all that
stuff we got other corner of our stuff
is it is this a cover or is it legit is
Trump sending just a few little you know
blockade ships to prevent the smuggling
of drugs well I mean he put a fifteen
million dollar bounty on his head is
that just an excuse because we're going
to war I don't know what do you just
like I don't exactly for
where do you trust the the information
from so far away you know it's like I
don't know what's going on you know but
but it is fair to say you know them
going after Maduro for drugs when when
Venezuela no longer has access to
valuable oil or I should say their
valuable oil isn't valuable anymore what
else do they sell drugs can they create
how that has been so this a long time it
could be an inversion Trump could be
deploying this for legitimate drugs you
know because of the drug stuff yeah
and Maduro may be lashing out because
they're about to lose their only other
lucrative trade yep that's a good point
so maybe it doesn't escalate beyond that
but there's a few other things so let's
move forward to us out the trail State
Department said the Department of State
urges Americans not to delay travel home
transportation options may soon be
unavailable US citizens should make
plans to return home now so we have this
right here Russia shut down and
unexpectedly cancelled
Aeroflot flight 102 the government of
the Russian Federation ordered this is
the immediate suspension of all
international flights without warning
until further notice man that's this
this is you show me earlier and like
this is this is a pressing man like
what's gonna happen we're we're bringing
all Americans back like everybody needs
to come back they're doing out there
doing evacuations yeah like what does
that mean it's like oh it's like they
don't need to be here because you're
probably gonna be not safe anywhere else
Burma the Embassy has coordinated a
repatriation flight scheduled to depart
Yangon April 6 at a scheduled to arrive
at San Fransisco 8:15 p.m. on April 6
please read alert for instructions look
at this there's tons of alerts and they
all say similar things the US government
is working to organize flights for US
citizens in Cabo Verde these flies are
protected to take place the week of
April 5th they're evacuating yeah the
embassies are evacuating now they are
finding commercial flights as well the
whole embassies being emptied out is
that what's happening no I'm at oh I
don't know oh ok ok
you said they're evacuating the eyes
it's like I would wasn't I would say
probably because I got a fact check me
on this once I didn't pull up but I'm
pretty sure that the State Department
allowed u.s. embassy work
and diplomatic personnel to evacuate
China back in like January okay one of
the first things they did so I think it
was someone from Fox and remember who
said if if they're telling us government
personnel to evacuate yeah then American
citizens you need to get out now
yeah definitely now of course this is
obviously corona virus pandemic related
is it I thought they already went
through this with the corona virus right
like I telling everybody to come on yeah
right they did it so this is not the
crow what I'm saying is it's the simple
solution there's no other reason like on
the surface it makes the most sense that
they're instructing people to come back
because flights are being canceled now
okay but it doesn't mean it's a
guarantee that's exactly why the dirt is
a lot of I have countries shutting their
borders down right shutting but that
happened a while ago a month ago or
whatever it's yeah progressively
happening more I had a friend who got
who's in a foreign country got
instructed to fly back immediately weeks
ago weeks and weeks ago yeah so they're
they're doing this now you're right
maybe it's because something else is on
the horizon I don't know I mean
Venezuela going crazy is pretty scary
yeah but look we can speculate and we
can be we can we can say I think my
opinion is I honestly don't know yeah
and the simple solution is just pandemic
related but check this out
I hope so you're ready for the
full-blown conspiracy theory oh we've
been facing war with China and and Iran
and some other countries for a long time
like it's been bubbling up and we've
talked about this let's say the
government knew war was inevitable how
would they okay if and I I've actually
I've actually said this in the past year
if China some I could snap their fingers
and cut us off which means we can't go
to war with them they would freeze all
of our manufacturing and we would be
left helpless no medicine so how does
the government the United spent get all
the manufacturing back secure its
borders and bring all its citizens back
in one month while also starting up all
these factors creating medicines that
are keeping like I'm medical some alive
millions and millions of Americans alive
no no no no no and and the supply isn't
man
making medical supplies it's crazy
medicines antibiotics yeah exactly if
you were gonna go to war what would you
need to do you would need to have that
stuff bring your citizens back kickstart
your manufacturing up yeah
secure your borders yeah and what did we
just do all those things in reverse
order we're doing this serious
close he closed the borders now now he
has the ability to go you're making
medicine you're making you're making
medical supplies you're doing this yep
guns are essential businesses that was a
trump order interesting good work on our
essays now it doesn't listen I'm not
joking I think I'm joking no I'm dead
serious but to clarify for those that
don't know oh yeah New Jersey requires
you to write an essay if you want to buy
a weapon yeah so still well it's gonna
be pretty easy right now - you don't
need clean y-you don't need to because
when the war starts they're gonna
they're gonna can script you and be like
here's your gun buddy yes there you go
guard your home that'll work for America
I was so there's a few things that about
that you know people have called out
Trump like the the drug operations in
Venezuela to say it's a distraction from
the pandemic they say you know like why
is Trump securing our borders and you
know bring people back it's just more of
his xenophobic nationalism the argument
from a lot of people has always been
that the things Trump is doing doesn't
specifically relate to the coronavirus
and so in that sense the people who have
criticized Trump's actions as though
they don't matter yeah
they would be making the argument that
it is not a simple solution that these
things are related to the coronavirus
you know and you kind of made a point
earlier about these media people that
are good with specific areas you know I
know this section of the world I know
this section of the world well there's
people that don't even worry about
sections of the world they worry about a
person right now and they don't they're
not even looking over here at this part
of the world so they don't see the full
picture clearly they don't because
they're so like polarized on what he's
doing and it's like it doesn't matter
that's why it doesn't matter what he
says because they don't even see what
the big picture is they're just like he
said something we can get a bunch of
clicks let's light this one up yeah the
next story Trump claims Iran or its
proxies are planning a
attack warns of a heavy price now I look
at this store I say what else is new or
its approximate else is new this stuff
happens all the time right yeah I agree
but here's my favorite World War 3 fears
domino effect era could spark major u.s.
Iran conflict in Middle East
hmm now well I shouldn't is my favorite
I there's another story I want to point
out that I think it's better but it's
just we're looking if you look at one
moment people might say oh we see these
things all the time right look at
Venezuela Venezuela all we see these
things all the time when I was when you
zoom out do they happen all at the same
time when the u.s. is evacuating its
citizens around the world securing its
borders and bringing manufacturing back
while a worldwide pandemic is happening
yep it's like and even with it all
together and Europe and people are
fighting over resources yeah
so at the very least here's what I could
say maybe there's you know I was
speculating and getting a bit
conspiratorial as if this is all a part
of a plot to you know build up America's
defenses before war starts the reality
is the pandemic is happening everyone's
being affected by it
right and it will likely be a
contributing factor to a major
escalation look Trudeau of Canada was
complaining that Trump just seized all
these masks saying you can't say you
can't shoot him out there America's now
so 3m was gonna send mass to Canada
Trump was like nope defense production
act boom they're ours and Trudeau was
like whoa whoa whoa we need these things
and they may be yep that's what we're
learning but but what what happens next
Canada's in have the resources they
start freaking out other countries don't
have resources they freak out and when
someone's backed in a corner and it's
look man if someone's starving I'll tell
you what they're not gonna sit there on
their knees begging you for bread
they're gonna take it I mean they are
our allies so it's well it's America jr.
whatever okay well still it's like we
were so angry at China for turning those
boats around with the masks that were
coming to us so how can we be upset with
China for doing that if we're if we're
doing the same thing to Canada I'm dead
serious well upset
sure I'm people are upset cuz upset oh
no no I was upset right but this just
says to me that oh we got angry we're
like oh no they took our masks so Trump
orders everyone to come back right and
now we're closer and than ever at a war
yeah here you go here's my favorite
April 3rd 2020 South China Sea Beijing
I used to give Europe a sobering lesson
on it hostile standoff who said that
so this is Chinese milk let's let's
let's read it
Chinese military actions in the South
China Sea are partly aimed at securing
economic dominance as the region is a
key area for shipping of goods for
countries around the world but President
President Xi Jinping has also overseen
investments in Europe which have mostly
flown into the radar in 2019 the
Financial Times reported out China's
invested in trieste on the northern
Adriatic Sea and Genoa Italy's biggest
seaport heading to a growing network of
seaports well you know yeah here you're
gonna shut them down the Financial Times
article states how this growing presence
in Europe should provide a sobering
lesson for Europe this is because while
China's trade can bring opportunities
its actions in the South China Sea prove
it isn't always the friendliest partner
so right now it's not just about the
trade routes and the conflict the
lasering of our planes why is the FBI
going around arresting collaborators of
China why aren't they they are oh they
are yes numerous professors have been
there's an investigation going on from
the FBI targeting these professors and
not much of them other people and they
found that numerous professors were
taking cash from China and did not
disclose it in fact one of them I think
lied to the feds and said I wasn't
getting paid they were they were setting
up their own labs in China working at
our universities feds are arresting them
good as part of that same investigation
those documents got publi leaked I guess
and Yahoo published this that the US has
intercepted on more than one occasion
Chinese researchers illicit Li
transporting viruses that's who they
were bringing them to yes they're
American potentially professors they
said it was part of the same
investigation this is all this is all
legit it's all happening Wow so perhaps
his espionage has been going on for a
long time maybe just coming out now
but I'll tell you what it feels like the
volcano is bubbling up it's getting
really close to breaking the surface
yeah it's smoking and eventually
someone's gonna get desperate
maybe Venezuela already did maybe
trouble they are yeah they're desperate
there are branding chips and losing
their own chips but it's like they're
clearly desperate they're they're
lashing out maybe that's the spark Trump
sends these ships down mm-hmm
and some other countries are like yo yo
what are you doing going after Maduro
some other countries are like we can't
let you do this
Trump says su has anyone said that is
anyone coming to Venezuela Zaid I don't
see it I feel that I would have heard
something so Venezuela's three biggest
out allies are China Iran and Russia
you'll get what a surprise oh yeah yeah
I did see I did see some comments saying
that yeah I didn't know if it was true
ready to ride that nuclear gravity bomb
down like a cowboy on a bull yeehaw baby
World War three so so I mean my Morken
spirits between spirit oriole minded
friends are freaking out I don't blame
them saying get out time to go to the
country I got a bunch of emails being
like you don't understand it's time to
get out of the city because we're in the
nuclear era man this doesn't there's a
that you know what you might have
restraint from any of these countries
for now and then eventually when they
realize they're losing mutually assured
destruction means nothing I think San
Diego is probably the the biggest area
that would be hit first right it's our
biggest port San Pedro right I thought
San Diego was I don't support on the
west coast I don't know if it's San
Diego but I know the San Pedro Report
which is basically LA okay yeah it's
like south of Los Angeles thank Pedro I
think it's San Pedro I just drive past
it all the time right
yeah maybe but I mean we're on the East
Coast so like what would you know in New
York like no rads over here isn't it so
it's like dude listen one multiple
independently targeted re-entry vehicle
with ten warheads on it could wipe out
the eastern seaboard yeah you're right
like the major cities just so I'm not
saying I don't know I don't know I don't
want to get that crazy I I feel like I
have more I just believe in the American
military because they've been getting so
much money over the past years yes it's
like bureaucracy government sluggishness
yeah you know but don't you think that
they have you I mean we talked about it
they gotta have stuff we don't know
about totally absolutely like the
Manhattan Project we didn't know until
they long until they dropped those bombs
yeah and then it was like whoa that's a
huge bomb like what just happened it's
like oh yeah by the way we've been
working on that with scientists this
like this is what scares me about World
War three mm-hmm
a lot of people have said mad mutually
assured destruction guarantees we
wouldn't see that kind of the kind of
conflict
right yeah if we're let's say we go to
war and it's Russia and China okay and
then we storm the beaches of Hong Kong
greeted as liberators and we charge in
and we're sweeping through the land and
Zhi Shan ping is getting cornered his
room it's not gonna be like Hitler and
Nazi Germany where he you know put a
bullet in his head or whatever no he's
gonna hit the bug he's gonna be like
you're going down with me
Wham yep yep yep
nukes plural and then you're gonna be
sitting in Philly and you're gonna be
like looking up what is that and then
you're gonna see a shock and a flash and
then you're blind yeah and then a few
seconds later are gonna go and then
you're gonna be a shadow on the wall
you're gonna be she I don't - wall man
that's you know maybe they'll get that
crazy maybe they'll be that angry I
refuse to go down I'll take you with me
I don't know they are that does seem
fairly extreme we can rewind everything
all the way back to where we are right
now and get away from all that
speculation and to just say one thing
this is the craziest it's ever been in
my life I hate this is insane and so if
there was ever a time to speculate as to
the end being nigh yeah would certainly
be now you know what really scared me
what I was thinking about something
earlier I know I didn't realize how much
Donald Trump's words actually affected
me really over the past couple of weeks
I was feeling like this is boring
nothing's happening everything felt fine
because Trump was telling Trump kept
saying we're gonna reopen thing is not a
big deal when Trump came out and said
this is gonna be the roughest couple of
weeks our nation has ever faced I mean
he said today though that it you know
it's it's bad but we're gonna get
through this it's you know it was kind
of like it felt like a couple weeks ago
not like last the past few days where
he's like this is gonna get bad but that
got really bad you know III didn't
realize that I guess like subconsciously
when you look to the President and he
acts like he doesn't care it really does
affect you is true like you're like if
he doesn't care why should I yeah and
that's that's normal for how people
react in in positions where you're
looking to the leader who's in charge of
the stuff yeah and that's what they say
and like when they're teaching people to
be leaders display calm and and optimism
and the people will feel good and look
their morale will be better when Trump
came out and said it's getting bad
all of a sudden you know I'm looking at
the news and I'm like boom it was all
the tank in the armor yeah you know you
thought you saw through the facade a
little bit like not that it was a facade
but just like you could see that he was
starting to feel the pressure himself
yeah you know and it showed yeah I know
what you mean yeah so there was a guy
paddleboarding by himself yeah he got
arrested they told us you couldn't go
outside and go for walks and go exercise
and they said it was no big deal
governor Murphy in New Jersey was like
go outside you know go for a walk do
your thing just don't gather in groups a
woman was in Florida walking around down
I think was in Florida walking around
downtown cops arrested her by herself
now she's got an ankle monitor what yeah
I don't understand that though what
they're worried she could be infected
she she had thought she had some she
said she had symptoms okay and she was
walking around by herself
Facebook liveing people call the cops
the cops came arrested her what is the
deal there that doesn't make any sense
clearly was doing social distancing to
the max he was by herself here's here's
here's work in the middle of nowhere I
mean the city but who's in the city
walking around these are other people
you know no there's no well she did go
into a grocery retail store or something
I like walked around a retail store was
open I guess or maybe she was looking in
the window I don't know okay the
paddleboating guy the paddleboarding got
that's crazy to me to to lifeguard
you know boats or whatever cruise up and
our Coast Guard I think and then he goes
to the shore and they arrest him they
walk him out that's nuts
he was in the ocean by himself
exercising some woman gave a quote where
she said she was worried the virus was
getting in the water and then being
kicked up into the air and I'm like
that's insane dude the how is that where
where where are these large quantity of
viruses all across the ocean yeah what
are you talking about right
like if could have even survived in that
kind of an environment do you yeah so
marine animals eat a lot of them a lot
of but think about them they serve on a
hold on and they save us from a lot of
them actually think about that vast open
space in the ocean okay yeah yeah I
could imagine there may be some virus
somewhere but the idea that's all up in
the air and he's swimming throats they
have to arrest him just cuz the waves
are like hitting the rocks and splash I
went oh right
I know but there's rocks along the the
whole coastline though you know where he
while a mist in the air in the morning
right right you know when you I'm
wondering is there another reason why
the coast guard was clearing out the
water for one person that's a really
good question what do you think that
they're watching out into the ocean for
I don't know not the virus I've know
something other than the virus you know
you know about that guy who got fired
from the captain of that aircraft
carrier who got fired I don't know much
about it Theodore what was name
Crozier Crozier he was worried that the
virus was in the ship and it was yes can
help yes well okay he got relieved
because they said that the letter
getting leaked made what will make our
enemies think that our military is weak
or weakened and so they replaced him
loose lips sink ships that's fair though
it is yeah but it's also scary right now
when Venezuela is ramming cruise line as
an opening fire but did he maybe's did
he no you know that's not the point the
point is he put it in writing and at all
doesn't matter is that why I don't know
the point is the military just fired a
captain of a ship scared that the
enemies think we're weak right now yeah
why it's the most pressing thing for the
American military right now that one
ship the military looks weak yeah is
there a concern that we will be attacked
for some reason if maybe they're
thinking if we do look weak that's more
it's raising the chance that we're gonna
get attacked maybe right but what does
any American think in there like I don't
have you at home right now thinking like
well it's just a matter of time until
America gets attacked it's it's not even
a part of our daily no one thinks at any
point anyone is gonna go after an
aircraft carrier but the US military
just relieved a guy saying loose lips
sink ships ships worried that he made
our military look weak why is there a
concern we might be attacked by an
opportunistic foreign got versary who's
looking for a chance to strike certainly
feels like it oh yeah man it does and
that brings me to the next portion of
the segment the conflict with our own
allies yeah and what that leads us to
and I don't know about that but I will
say if Canada is is in dire straits and
there and then and look Canada and
Russia are right next to each other
people often don't look at the map and
think about what the North Pole
we live in a global got the picture
right here the little of the planet
Canada's right there it's a hop skip and
a jump to Russia yeah
what happens if Canada's you know
running out of resources we have no
choice but to help them okay we're gonna
start seeing factions forming like
shrunk I mean obviously it's already the
BRICS nations there's NATO Canada is
like they're angry at us but eventually
they're gonna need supplies venezuela
clearly does they're gonna ask for help
this how the factions start forming and
then thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you